good my name is Nikolai Azotus I am
trying to enable the pointer so I'm
involved in the Cephas pasteurization
for 20-25 years written some books from
the beginning and in the beginning I
kept mostly for the library now I care
for everything the problem is they
screwed up the language that much
theater I have to deal with that so
because I had problems using it in the
library no just kidding
oh this is recorded too bad good now we
do a good job
we are 200 people now standardized in
C++ please note this is not chief
architect behind we have 200 programmers
with different ideas different interests
different experience and we do the best
we can and if you want to complain about
the C++ standard I will always say it's
your fault because you haven't been
there so come there and help us to make
it even better that's it umm that's not
the end of the talk that begin the end
of the beginning of the talk it doesn't
work that way I have to put up my jacket
smart pointers No yeah let's talk about
smart pointers why do we have smart
pointers well because we're all pointers
suck we have a lot of big problems with
that one of the biggest problems we have
is polymorphism in C++ although i
yesterday introduced that we have a new
option called variant where we can avoid
using pointers when we want to have
polymorphism and heterogeneous
collections we still need it in various
ways so let's look at the motivational
example for smart pointers here I assume
we have a hierarchy for polymorphism so
base class geometric objects and then
circle and line as a concrete class
derived from that and the pointers
you only have polymorphism in
collections if you use references or
pointers references are not allowed so
we have to use pointers in for example a
vector and when we initialize a vector
of elements that looks like the
following let's create the vector of the
elements the elements are pointer as I
said let's create the elements don't
create them on the stack because if you
create them on the stack and at the
address of this element in the vector
the abject we refer to is gone when we
return the vector so we have to create
it on the heap here a line and circle we
push them back into the vector and we
return the whole thing to the caller and
the column might initialize an object
and see here that all local objects are
gone but fortunately we created the
objects are in the heap so we still have
them and we can use them and perform our
polymorphic code for example here called
draw and at runtime there is a decision
which draw function to call depending on
whether we can t have a circle or line
here okay so far so good
so the only problem we have left is
let's remove the element and there's
important thing here it's not enough to
just to call clear if you call clear you
have a memory leak you have to make sure
that before we remove the element with
the only raw pointers we have called
delete for the corresponding new call
here you see one example to do it just
start a loop over all the elements with
our pointers we might not only call the
lead we might also want to ensure that
all the elements are now point us now so
we iterate by reference over pointers so
that we can call delete and then assign
to the pointers the null pointer so
things like that happen if you use
polymorphism with Rob
- so how can we do better there's one
principle in C++ which is very important
our AI I resource acquisition is
initialization which means put something
you have to clean up in an object so
that a destructor can call the
corresponding cleanup when it goes out
of scope so what we need here is
something like a smart pointer that says
whenever this pointer goes out of scope
let's then automatically call delete and
that's roughly the idea of smart
pointers that we have a way to say well
instead of us calling delete which might
create some trouble we might call it too
late or too early
so let's decide the pointers what to do
and one thing we provided even before
C++ 11 well shared pointers
well you could do that and yet pointers
also had another benefit you could still
have different owners different pointers
referring to the same object so by using
smart pointers we implement a way that
the compiler doesn't work for us and we
make less mistakes so we have two
concepts of set of smart pointers in C++
since C++ 11 we are a third one called
Auto pointer please don't use it we come
to there later and share pointers and
unique pointers that I both introduced
with C++ 11 let's look at them so the
first example is let's use a shared
pointer here and a shared pointer we
introduced a type here for that just the
type definition clear pointer is a share
point of geometric object so this is a
smart pointer now and the smart pointer
changes the behavior a little bit first
of all the usual way to create it is use
make share and what happens here is we
create the vector and then when we call
make shared two things happen we create
an object on the heap and we create a
counter
the counter might be bound to the object
or might be not make sure it usually
bounce them together which is a little
bit misleading in this picture here
because they look like two different
objects we come to that later but the
key thing is beside creating an object
on the heap we create a counter
somewhere somewhere available over the
lifetime of this returned pointer share
pointer so it also has to be created on
the heap so the two things there the
counter and the objects are on the
reheat the rest is on the stack I should
use different colors here to make that
clear and then let's call another make
share call which does the same thing for
a circle and now the trick is that this
pointer is Matt and that means that it
finds out how many owners we have and
when the last owner dies the object the
delete for the object will automatically
be called so we pass both shared
pointers into the vector and you see
that this increases the owner count so
we now we share from two different
positions we refer we point to this
object and when we then return it we
might even temporarily create a third
pointer that temporarily also refers to
the object but this might be the return
vector if you create a new one and copy
all the elements but on the other hand
we leave the function and that means
that we remove all the local objects on
the stack which is both the LP and CP
shared pointer single objects and the
local vector of pointers here this might
be optimized yes I know but the point is
yeah we have a counter we know always
know how many owners we have and here
for example Crowley we only have one
owner for each object we have so we can
use it as an ordinary pointer so if we
iterate over all the elements you can
still iterate the datatype is cons to
the pointer but you can still use Auto
here
Auto and even Nazi that you use a
slightly different type here and we have
polymorphic cards because the error
operator in smart pointer has overloaded
that we over a row pointer internally
use call the right draw and decide at
runtime which draw to call that's it and
the good thing is at the end we clear
all the elements and the vector and now
the magic happens as you just saw it
clear just removes the elements so we
call the destructive hunter which is the
last owner of the element so as we are
the last owner the moment we decrement
the own account to zero we automatically
called in it and we have no memory leak
we need it at the moment we no longer
need it that's to some extent just an
implementation of reference counting in
a data type good so far by the way look
at that we use make shared here make
sure it has its drawbacks there is a
rumor in the community that makes share
it is always good that's not true
we will come also to that so instead of
using make sure you might do two steps
you might first call a new and the end
for the objects and then pass the return
draw a pointer to a sharepoint ax and we
will see why this is sometimes better
than using make shirt what is the
alternative the alternative is using a
unique pointer and maybe we go to this
alternative later i already change the
order of my slides it happens from time
to time so let's look first now into
details of shared pointers so what's
your point us as i said you can call new
to create an object so if you have a set
pointer and later on create new call new
you have this object created and return
a raw point and then you pass the
ownership of this from this raw pointer
to a sharepoint and that cree
this control block and the control block
is created on the heap and each
operation you call is an indirect access
to the underlying object so far so good
so if we assign this object to another
shared pointer like here the other share
pointer can also access the element and
the owner counter goes to two if we
leave the scope the inner scope we only
have left the outer scope pointer and if
we leave that we delete the pointer so
far so good that's a basic principle of
a shared pointer there are some good
things like you can define your own
delete us so that means that you not
only can use it for resources created
with new you can also use that for
resources created for example with an F
or P open call where we return another
kind of pointer where we need some
cleanup at deletion time so here for
example on the top we call P open to
open the pipe and then we can specify
ideally as a lambda or as an example in
a lambda that we call pre close to clean
up the resource there's one concept here
called weak pointers so beside off her
pointers we have another brother or
sister of shared pointers which is a
weak pointer a part of the concept of
share pointers it is an observer that
does not count as an owner and so it
uses the principle of shared owner and
of smart pointers but if you use it it
does not count as an owner so an object
will die if the last shared pointed eyes
even if weak pointers still referred to
them but the good thing is you can find
out when the weak pointer daggits so you
can ask the weak pointer is there still
in an object so far why do you use that
first of all to resolve cyclic
references cyclic pointers because
otherwise you would never clean up
a combination of multiple objects
because there's always one owner like
here resource a points to resource B and
resource B parts to resource a and we
only have a set point outside point into
resource a so somebody needs resource a
and resource a needs resource B but they
have a back pointer which is a very
common case here we also use an observer
to observe is there still a resource a
so the moment we delete here the shared
pointer we have deleted the last owner
of resource a because the back pointer
from resource B is not a shared pointer
does not count as an owner it's a weak
pointer so that means we delete resource
a or indirectly so automatically the
destructor will D call delete for the
resource a and that will delete the last
owner is of resource B so that will be
leader and that's the effect of deleting
the shared pointer on the left side
there's still the weak pointer and you
can ask the weak pointer is there still
something available or not this is
important that we have the concept of
weak pointer there's a reason you have
to take that into account as you will
see in a moment let's see how to use a
weak pointer a weak pointer looks like
it is also share pointer so you might
assume to use it we need a pointer API
but that's not true it does not use a
pointer API so here if we create
something and have a SharePoint as an
owner and then we have a weak pointer as
an observer you can't directly use the
arrow operator to access the object
you're pointing to you have first to
lock the object and the lock will give
you a shared pointer back why that
because of multi-threading because if we
why we are from an observer dealing with
the resource are and then the last
shared pointer dies why we are using it
we are in big trouble so the trick is
that lock creates a new SharePoint at
early or not temporarily and that means
even if SP now dies and we still have an
owner which is P as long as we have P we
can use it and that safe code even in
multi-threading environments so now with
P we can call a member function and you
can do that also in one step creating a
shared pointer from a weak pointer but
here you get an exception if the weak
pointer refers to some object that is
already gone
please don't program it that way there's
also a member function is there still a
shared pointer is there still an object
and because the answer might be old if
you use it so if the answer is true
then you call lock-on comment without
checking the return value of LOC you are
using a null pointer here this is not
thread safe because between the core of
expired and lock that somebody might
have deleted the last owner of the
object so do it the other way around
good this weak pointer has consequences
for the concept and implementation of
shared pointers so let's look at this
example we have outside a weak pointer
we have outside the share pointer and
then we have a shared pointer which we
directly initialize with the return
value of a call of mu and the point is
we have in fact two counters now because
of weak point us in the control block in
the control block we have to count how
many owners we have and we have to count
how many weak pointers we have and the
reason is pretty clear at the moment we
use this example we have one owner so
let's assign this to another owner so we
have two owners now and now let's assign
this tool to an observer to a weak
pointer so far so good so why do we have
different contests because if we delete
if the first owner nothing happens just
we decrement the own account but if we
delete the last owner we can deal
the resource but I can't delete the
control block because the control block
contains the information the weak
pointer has to give us to explain is
there still an object or not otherwise
we have no memory to hold this
information so that means we still have
to keep the control box alive and now
the weak pointer can tell us no there is
no longer a resource so if we try loc
try to call lock it will again self give
if as an ID pointer as a shed pointer on
non initialized yet pointer so only if
the last weak pointer dies the object of
the control block is gone ok so we have
two pointers fine so now we come to make
sure so in the internet and maybe also
in the community you always learn that's
always use make sure it's always better
that's a lie that's not correct because
look at the same example I just went
through
by using SharePoint
excuse me make share so the point is the
trick of make share this and that's one
benefit of it it calls not new twice
because we call new for the results and
we call new for the counter it calls new
only once so it creates something like
this it elekid's memory for both the
control block and the resource so we
save in the control plug a pointer and
we save a call of new so that's a good
thing that that is faster and therefore
usually better so however we have
introduced a problem now if we now copy
the shared pointer to another set
pointer and introduce an observer to
this resource okay everything is fine
but now let's delete the first owner so
by leaving the scope here the inner
scope
and now let's leave the middle scope
where the last owner is valid so now we
have an interesting situation we can
delete the resource but we have to keep
the control Vogel life because there is
the information for the weak part to
give us an answer for does this object
still exist or not so we have to keep
this control book alive but the lifetime
of the control block is bound to the
memory of the resource because we only
have a located in one memory one piece
of memory so that means we can't delete
the memory we can call the destructor
and we do it but we can't delete the
memory or free the memory of the whole
thing which means if you use meg shared
and you're using weak pointers and your
resources allocate a huge amount of
memory you have an interesting logical
resource leak by not deleting or
destroying all your weak pointers if you
just keep the weak pointers alive the
memory of your resources will never be
freed and I've seen that and at least
one project where we thought we have a
memory leak but it was just a logical
error that we never destroyed the weak
pointer still observing the object so
beware of that if you have that
situation don't use make shared do it in
two steps call new and then assign the
ownership to a shared pointer so that
over a long period of time when the
object was destroyed the last owner was
destroyed you can still use a weak
pointer and you give up the memory ok
good so only if we then destroy the last
weak point us then we will free the
whole memory so that's the first thing
let's talk about a few other things I'm
one of my things is well we came from an
example motivating about polymorphism so
we had an example where we have two
objects circle and nine so interesting
question is
first of all can we use smart pointers
like ordinary pointers and as one thing
you might know that which you see is a
relationship we can say a circle isn't
geometric object align is a geometric
object so we can use them as that one
there's an important rule when you use
inheritance which is is air relations
inheritance relationships don't
propagate to collections of the types so
if you have a base class like geometric
object and you can say a circle is a
geometric object it does not mean that
the collection of circles is a
collection of geometric objects because
a key API of the is air relationship a
key feature of it is a relationship is
that you can do everything with the
derived class you can do with the base
class so if you have a collection of
geometric objects what can you insert a
circle and a line if you have a
collection of circles it would not be
very well if we could insert a line so
that's the usual logical rule we have
and that applies to inheritance and the
is a relationship in general and thanks
goodness we have implemented that in C++
you can see that so if you create a
vector of geometric objects if you use a
base term so a geometric object pointer
you can push back a circle pointer and
the line pointer that's fine
but if you create a vector of circle
pointers you cannot push back a line
pointer and that is implemented in the
logic of templates the way the standard
there the the the language can do that
as I say if there is
and is a relationship between types this
relationship does not propagate if I
pass these types as a template parameter
that's the way we realize this rule and
that applies to everything that even
applies that we if we use a collection
or just any template if we use any
template that there is no relationship
anymore between types like being
inheriting or saying this is the
conversion so there's an implicit
conversion from a non cons object to a
con subject etc so we have to implement
that in our types which we do and
sometimes and so we need some support
some support of the in the in the in the
template code to program that and that's
a safety feature that this does not work
yeah
that's not to blame you so therefore we
had to implement new dynamic cast
operations for shared pointers so and we
had to introduce a dynamic pointer cast
because a shared pointer is also just
taking the type of the elements so we
have a problem with propagating there is
a relationship to the template types to
the template file types so here is if
you create a vector of shared pointers
and you push them back and the element
you have if you ask it what are you I'm
a shared pointer to a geometric object
and you can't directly use it as a
shared point of circle as it's always
the case with pointers but you can also
not dynamic cast so downcast it with the
key word dynamic has to its downcast to
the type of circle again to implement
some special behavior we had to
introduce a new dynamic pointer cos a
new operator and with that things work
and that own does not only apply to
downcast that also applies
to the other castes so therefore we have
in SharePoint a static point occurs
consequent occurs and since C++ 17 we
also have introduced reinterpret pointer
cast which I what always the which is at
least as much as a smell as reinterpret
cast alone okay
yeah this slide you should not see yet I
school am the aura good anything else to
talk about
yes there's one problem left one problem
is don't create multiple shared pointers
of the same raw pointer because then you
have two objects thinking they are the
only owner of this pointer that's
another good reason to use make sure
that if you don't use weak pointers
because you don't see raw pointers at
all so you don't fall into this trap
however the problem is we can't easily
avoid this trap if we just use objects
and for example a member function of our
object shall return a pointer to this
object we want to avoid row pointers so
let's return a shared pointer of the
object and that's not supported because
a share point as a wrapper around an
object and now we are asking for that
the object returns this Reppert I'm so
we have a cyclic dependency between
things here the way to support that
which is a workaround and it does not
always work well is that we have a base
class and able shared from this and this
enable shared from this class let me see
let me animate what it does so this
means that you have to derive your data
type from a base class and able shared
from this and what it does in the base
class it creates a weak pointer for you
which is initialized with an ID pointer
and then
if you then create your first shared
pointer this weak pointer becomes a
shared pointer or becomes a point of
their own to this memory it doesn't
become shared pointer so by the way that
means before you didn't create a shared
pointer you can access useful the the
share pointer from this object but the
moment you have it you can call chat
from this and if you call chat from this
for an object then this will give you a
new SharePoint are using the same
control block as I said that's a
workaround it has some impact because
for example you have to derive from
another class now it has interesting
problems if you have multi inheritance
it's a rock around it's it's kind of a
heck it works in many cases but not in
all so yeah we are feeling a little bit
uncomfortable I'm uncomfortable already
with shared pointers but it gets worse
performance let's look at performance so
first of all we have some overhead we
have this control block object which has
to be allocated on the heap something
like I don't know
I measured somewhere but that's not
approved 16 bytes maybe 4 additional
bytes if you have a non-trivial deleter
there and using make shared usually
saves 4 bytes and usually a deriving
from enabler shared from this you might
add 8 bytes to each object something
like this something around this corner
so some overhead and for each chat point
I have one call on the heap if you don't
combine them with make sure twitch head
which has its own problem so but we have
another problem and the other problem we
have to talk about this multi-threading
if we have the following situation we
have a share pointer declared SP here
and this red pointer is used
at the same time in two different
threats on the left on the right so the
threat on the Left pushes it back into a
vector the vector creates a copy
therefore and the threat on the right
passes it by value to a function which
also means we copy the shared pointer so
the problem we run into is a following
we have an object owning the resource
and now at the same time two threads try
to copy this shared pointer which mean
at the same time they want to increase
the ownership of this pointer that's not
good distributed programming and
multi-threading is good as long as you
don't have to share the same object
otherwise you pay a price because you
have to send around the data and even
worse you might have to synchronize the
access to that data and that's the case
here and the we discussed whether we
want to have it or not in the early
implementations of shared pointers at
boost
this was not synchronized but during the
standardization we came up with the
defect you see it here 896 it is and
this defect was discussed and before C++
11 we decided that we give the guarantee
that you can use that you can account on
the fact that it is safe to copy your
share pointer that's not that in general
share pointers are thread safe so all
the operations or the other operations
you have to synchronize but just copying
a shared pointer
is Fredd safe you see it in the last
sentence here changes in the use count
do not reflect modifications that can
introduce a data race data raises our
time term for race undefined behavior
due to a race condition good so that's
new good what is the prize well the
prices we have to improve something with
the implementation because that means
that if you go back to the slide here
that means that our counters have to
somehow synchronize the access which
means they have to become something like
Atomics or mutexes just a side note what
can happen is that one thread deletes
the last owner and another threat
deletes the last week pointer so both
threads think there's another thing when
they decrement but at the end we have
the zeros real situation where we had to
delete the control block so therefore we
not only have to synchronize between
threads the own account and the week
counter we even have a dependency
between them so we need some logic of a
protected region between them so that
whenever one of the threads is the last
thread so that both owner and week
pointer gets to zero then we have to
delete the control block the that can be
improved usually you don't use mutexes
because they are pretty expensive so a
way to do that is that the week pointer
in practice is not a weak pointer it is
a pointer that also counts how many
owners we have or says I add one for at
least one owner so we say we have an
owner counter and we have a week and
owner counter because then we don't need
a protected region to decide whether we
have to delete the control block then
it's enough to see whether the week end
owner counter decrements to zero okay so
it's tricky most Fricke then than we
think so we have that in the standard
and Atomics and synchronization between
threats and mutexes are expensive so the
question is how expensive are they I
have provided a program here and the
program let's see the program does
roughly the following I have 1,000
elements I have
counter for 1 million iterations and
what I do I initialize a vector of 1,000
elements or 1000 shared pointers
referring to an object and then I start
a loop and in this loop I do 1 million
iterations over these 1000 objects and I
perform a simple increment call in all
these objects I make sure that the
objects are not shared but the the
iterations of the share pointers might
be might be passed or used by different
threads and now the key point is while
I'm iterating over the SharePoint as I
can switch between a loop using auto
reference and a loop using auto without
a reference without a reference we would
copy all the SharePoint us without with
without reference we would copy the
SharePoint us with the reference we
would never copy any share pointer and
that's an example program I have and
that's compile and run it so here we
have it oh wait a minute I switch I
switch to the mode because I don't see
what I doing here I don't have a monitor
here for me so I come back so yeah now I
see it good so let's compile it make
shared pointer loop dot 14 that will use
GCC 5 5 as you see with - OH - and again
C++ version 13 compiler and now we can
use this program shared pointer loop it
has a couple of options so let's start
with having one thread and iterating by
reference once again we iterate over 1
million times over vector of 1000 shared
pointers and I made sure that the
operation is not optimized away there is
an optimal operation that is called and
that gives a result and here is the
current output for milliseconds let's
switch to iterate by value that's a
little bit slower so maybe you have
heard about the overhead but maybe it
surprises you a little bit how big the
overhead is please note that there's a
one I only use one thread that means
here you see how expensive it is to
generate a semblance incrementally
threats yeah and now you know why they
include guys who introduced this new
feature that they don't synchronize
threads unless they have to they
suddenly got effect of 10 or 100 or 1000
so let's use four threads by reference
first pretty much the same as before
you see that the output is screwed up
now from the for threat it seems that
here the amount of the cost of starting
additional threat pays off with the fact
that each threat has to be less and we
can do things in parallel so I divided
the 1 billion 1 million iterations
through the four threats so each for
each threat has only 250,000 iterations
so now let me task that they let me
start a task manager because that's
funny
[Music]
it is now let's use for threat and it's
a right by value
yeah let's drink a coffee and but you
also see another problem yeah the CPU
saw it what you see is what it takes for
CPU now constantly sending the counters
around the 1,000 candles around back and
forth between the different costs that's
the price of a share pointer and it's a
funny story how I created this talk when
I created this talk the reason I created
this talk I was sitting in a conference
press conference in Aspen and on stage
somebody was saying here this is a cool
spare pointer and you know what some
people pass shared pointers by reference
but that makes no sense because it's
just the share pointer it's a pointer so
why should you pass it by reference so I
phoned up my chief architect from a
project I was currently in and I said
why do we have the rule always pass the
shared pointer by reference because they
say that stupid and he answered they
have no clue and here's a reason you saw
that and and and there's a real story
behind it was a project where they
invented a new database based on many
many many using many threats and this
database had to scale and they used
shared pointers and everywhere because
they thought it's a good programming
paradigm and it turned out when they
started to use it in real practice the
database got on hold because of they
were only sending around shared pointers
and this is not the first project I know
now that that happened to a couple of
projects that they thought Oh share
pointers there's no problem let's use
them everywhere and that's good so you
see the price here so yes it's it's not
against share pointers use them but use
them with care and especially don't pass
him around by value
if you can't pass them around by
reference because they're not they are
as fast as Rob pointers good so that's a
price that's a real price of shared
pointers and you should know it wait a
minute
I want to switch back to my normal
presentation mode now the interesting
thing is that my presentation is gone so
and we have different numbers it's not
the exact factor that counts we have
different numbers here's a in the
project where I just talked about we
also did some measurements and we saw
that the overhead was about factor of 40
and with - all three it became effect of
80 this was using 8 threads on the end
will cost something and and you could
see there 20 82 percent of the time the
CPU was waiting to get access to an
owner counter that was a problem so it
was stalled and if we pass - I found us
by Reverend
we were only waiting 16 percent of the
time so that's a point with red pointers
good so passing by shared pointers
that's the first lesson Oh
is there something better yes there is
something better that's unique pointers
so let's look at them first how we can
unique use unique pointers here at some
let's start with our basic example
polymorphism here we have them with
shared pointers but let's switch to
unique pointers so what's the difference
with unit pointers unique pointers you
can use like SharePoint us instead of
make sure you call make unique the type
is unique pointers that are shared
pointer but there's a difference they
don't count and they don't have to count
or the question is when they don't count
how do they know when the last owner
dies the trick they use is there can't
be a second owner that's all they do
they say we make sure
that there's always only one owner and
that's an interesting trick because you
can enforce this trick at compile time
you don't have to do anything at run
time all you do is you disable copying
and that's what they do and that's why
this from program now needs you see that
and move because it would not compile if
I call push back to push back this
pointer into a vector we make sure that
if you push back the unique pointer into
the vector this will be moved the
ownership will be moved into the vector
and the ownership of the circle pointer
will be moved and when we then return
the whole thing then because we have
moved semantics here when we return a
vector of elements we have moved
semantics and that means that we move
the elements to the one who gets the
result because the elements and the
vector are dying that where we move the
elements from so we don't have to do
anything here so let's use them as
before
let's iterate over them with
polymorphism and please note that you
can all can now not compile iterating by
value you have to iterate by reference
because it's not allowed to copy a
unique pointer and the good thing is now
when we call clear it's easy each Pro
teach element each unique pointer knows
whether it is an own or not and if it's
an owner it can only be the only one
because it's not possible to to screw
there up well it is if you pass a row
pointer to twice to two different unique
pointers but then it's your fault so we
can then safely delete the pointer okay
and if you don't like move create call
make unique and pass it directly to push
back and you have the same effect
so that
that's a cheap rock partner that's a one
of the few cases where we create more
significant more safety without overhead
without performance overhead because the
type system is our friend and we
introduce that and seabass was 11 we
couldn't introduce that before c+ was 11
because we needed move semantics for
that our first try to implement move
semantics in a shared pointer was called
Auto pointer that was a nightmare
because we thought we could implement
move semantics in the copy constructor
of an auto pointer and that created some
interesting problems so if you have an
auto pointer replaces by unique pointer
if it still compiles fine if not fix
this the places which might either need
a move or you have a code smell or you
have abused an outer part and we are you
have found it back ok that's a unique
pointer unique pointer to explain a
unique pointer that's easy we can create
it we can create a resource we can pass
the ownership to a unique pointer you
can't pass the ownership to another
object but you can move the ownership to
another object and that's a benefit of
unique point no overhead everything is
decided at compile time good so the
trick the unique pointers implemented is
simple we have deleted copying so we
have no copy constructor and no
assignment operator no copying
assignment operator we only have the
moving operations that do what you just
saw by the way make unique was not
available in C++ 11 we added it in C++
14 so before C++ 11 you have had to call
new and pass then the ownership to
unique porta so are there any problems
of course they are always there it's not
a performance problem but we have some
restrictions
I think the biggest description
restriction we have is it's not that
easy to have polymorphism well that's
easy
but to have a downcast back to the
original type so if we have that here
everything works fine
create a unique pointer push back
everything is fine but if you then
assign this to not oh my goodness
this slide is wrong but I'm pretty sure
I made it this morning at five o'clock
and I've fixed it but it seems I didn't
let's see probably it's here this is
screwed up let's hope the best yes good
so yeah so if you then access the first
element and first of all ultra would not
work here because you would create a
copy so you have to use cards out of
reference and the type is a unique
pointer and but you can't cast down and
we also can't create something like a
dynamic pointer cast or dynamic unique
pointer cast because what is the essence
of a dynamic cast it down casts you the
point and gives you a second pointer
referring to the same object that's by
intentionally exactly what we don't want
to have in unique pointers we don't want
to have to own us so we simply can't
provide a down cast operation for unique
pointers so that's probably the biggest
drawback and that means that you have to
use dynamic cast and the way you can use
it you can access the raw pointer behind
the unique pointer and then call
downcast and please be aware that you
don't use it longer than necessary so
because we have lifetime image issues
and never pass this to something like to
something like a another location where
people might create a unique pointer or
share pointer from that so that's the
way you have to do it and to make it a
little bit more safe you might say let's
do it in one expression so in the if
statement you can declare without all
the circle pointer and use it but this
make sure that at the end of the if
statement the lifetime of the raw
pointer is God so beware and it's a
problem to return a unique pointer for
an object that exists we don't have
support for that
yeah that's surprise there's always a
price there's no free lunch but the good
news is there is regarding performance
no overhead and that's a very important
aspect in our programming community
because one reason we have C++ often is
performance so if you can use unique
pointers use them and of discussion you
have to explain me if I see a small
share pointer that's a smell you have to
explain me why you don't use a unique
pointer there's another interesting
issue here a last issue here as you can
ownership move around ownership for
unique pointers you can do the following
you can say hey wait a minute
I inside a function I create a resource
I pass the ownership to a unique pointer
and I passed the ownership to the
calling side so that's easily to do you
don't need any move there just return it
by value because this return by value is
a call with move semantics because local
object is about to die so the calling
side can in a loop call this function
each time it called sauce it gets the
ownership of the created resource that
was created there and can use it and the
next time you in the loop call source
again you am delete because you are the
owner of the previously returned return
value you delete the ownership so you'll
call the need for the created resource
and you then become owner of the next
return value that's fine that's safe
programming and it's also possible the
other way around you can say let's pass
my ownership to a function what you do
then is a place out here in sync you
declare that you take the ownership of a
unique pointer so the caller then has to
pass an ownership by calling mafia
without the move it wouldn't compile
because then you would create a copy
here now there's an interesting there
there has been an interest interesting
discussion in our community between two
of the guys we usually ask if we ask for
style and good programming practice so
this is he hops arrest I I call it
because have supper said that's the way
you should do it
declare the unique pointer in the sink
to take the unique pointer by to take it
by be taken by value and then time Scott
Myers and said no no that's not the way
you should do it you should pass it by a
value reference because obviously we
have your move semantics so you should
signal that in the signature and they
started to discuss that and I think
finally perhaps that Scott Myers were
right but I don't agree with them I
think it's more complicated because this
is a nice demonstration of the feature
move semantics first of all both as
possible the difference is if you pass a
unique pointer to a function taking it
by value you will give up the ownership
okay because you create and you are
Jack this object gets the ownership this
object is destroyed at the end of the
function call so as a result in the
first part if you call if you pass it by
value you no longer are the owner of the
resource and it was freed in the second
part you only pass a reference and if
you pass a reference that means you
refer to the original unique pointer but
it depends on the implementation of this
function whether you use the ownership
or not so it's funny with mu semantics
if you don't signal move here so not
having to ampersand it will move if your
signal move here it might move that's
one of the interesting aspects of MU
semantics there are good reasons for
that but in general the the lesson down
here is pretty easy the lesson is if you
have marked something with move it might
or might not be moved because the
specification is after a call after
using a move from object the object is
an invalid but unspecified state well
four unique pointers we even specify the
state but I think it's good style not to
not to break this rule in C++ just four
unique pointers which by the way some
people try now by even adding more
interesting interfaces so if it's
important for you that the ownership was
gone don't count on the fact that thing
takes the argument by value or don't
count on the implementation of this
function if you pass it by reference
make it clear that this is your
assumption and you will and the way to
do that is after calling sync with move
you say I'm no longer
interested in the resource in this value
so the right way to call sing well
however it is declared and however it is
implemented is called move and then
called unique pointer release that way
you make sure and you have expressed
explicitly that is it is your will that
you are no longer interested in the
value of this object and the
corresponding resource should be freed
and you can be sure that it is free
please keep that in mind
star guides are like this are really
missing we are for problem in C++ we
have many many new techniques but we
don't have corresponding style guides
which we only learned over the past
years we had very early a book called
more effective effective modern C++ but
that was written eight seven years ago
we need a new book as a lot of things
have changed
looking back with C++ 11 which we should
have teach to users now as especially
regarding move semantics good find a
command yes there is an intentionally
very different approach and design for
your shared pointers and unique pointers
shared pointers were implemented and
designed to have no performance overhead
end of discussion
why share point us anyway needed
overhead because of the reference
counting that had to be stored somewhere
there's no way to go around that so we
could say yeah it's safe and we have we
can share ownership between different
places which you use a couple of times
in your programs but they have an
ownership and you see the difference in
the way you pass a bolita if you are
possibly later your own deleter to a
shared pointer it's enough to pass us
the leader and the constructor so here
again the P Clause which we pass
to the shed pointer despite calling peel
if you have to pass the Delita
to a unique pointer you have to pass it
twice because that the type of the
unique pointer has to transfer it
somewhere you need to make sure not to
confuse different unique pointers having
different deal eaters you have it should
become part of the type and also to be
able to starve there so that the unique
pointer suddenly has some memory some
member for this type for this member so
therefore you have to pass it twice once
as an additional argument that type of
the deleter and once in the constructor
which can be improved with c++ 20
because if c++ 20 it's allowed that we
instantiate a lambda later on we're
provided it has not captured every
anything so there ii you don't have to
pass it in the constructor
but the difference will remain the
shared pointer needs Adelita in the
constructor the unique pointer gets
Adelita as a template parameter that's a
difference and yes we know that
difference and yes we apologize but it's
the price of having very different
interests and implementation mechanisms
for shared pointer and unique pointer
that's the way it is we can't resolve
that easily that's it thank you very
much I hope this was useful I'm not long
time here around but for some questions
I'm around here for a few minutes and
yeah Merry Christmas and to pay if we
don't see until then thank you very much
[Applause]